o lateral diz pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos ao meu
dro my life você continuou se já viram
vários dramas life má gestão o meu por
escolas e isso é especial de 400 mil
inscritos
ok mas para lá era uma vez um rapaz que
nasceu em casa assim literalmente em
casa o que seria tão rápido que nem
investimento tivessem condições também
filme diz que os entes parada e bati com
a cabeça no aparelho obviamente isso
teve consequências no futuro né
op este facto gordo e gostoso neste ano
em portugal em 1994 eu era o mais novo
de quatro irmãos ou seja somos cinco é
que o bom em matemática que eu sou e por
ter sido o último filho fiquei com o
pior nome é antônio luís miguel que tem
este nome mas já ter um bebê feliz meu
pai faleceu quando eu tinha um ano por
isso a minha mãe teve que arranjar um
bigode para fazer o papel dos dois
quem me dera ter um bigode igual à vela
eu quando era pequeno tinha muitos
sonhos um deus era sempre treinar mas
isso era um sonho de toda a gente o time
ficar sem emprego e ficar pobre para
sempre e por isso decidi ser bombeiro e
um jatinho muito treinar casa de banho e
só mais tarde é que eu percebi que não
era assim que se pagavam os fogos por
isso rodas e diz que não que não tive
muitos amigos por isso eu brincava com
formigas sim eu sei que é triste mas já
era a única coisa que tava ali
o resultado comprova a amizade delas com
açúcar ou seja elas só criam pelo açúcar
até hoje eu espero que elas tenham
morrido com diabetes uma coisa assim até
que foi uma infância feliz tirando o
facto do meu irmão ter parte do braço
quando eu tinha 12 anos meu eu fiz um
truque do jogo ensina e eu nem sequer
havia resto enfim vamos salvar esta
parte e como não tinha amigos eu ficava
muito tempo em casa e passava horas de
ver os meus irmãos jogar nas consolas
deus eu mal consegui jogar porque eles
não deixavam e quando deixavam era
sempre a parte mais difícil que eles não
conseguiam passar
e de certa forma até foi bom porque
ganhei altas que eu só por jogar as
partes mais difíceis
o meu jogo favorito era o mário kart
para a nintendo 64 eu sempre esperava
que a minha família fosse dormir para eu
jogar à noite sozinho sem ninguém me
chatear mas mesmo os andores jogadores
sentindo um pouco sozinhos disse um dia
mudou
um dia meu irmão trouxe um cão para casa
e encontrou na rua e não conseguiu deixá
lo ia morrer né recebeu era um cocker eu
sei que parece um pouco mais geleira e
quase nem isto é o juro e quando eu vi
chegar a casa o síndico finalmente ter
um amigo uma companhia a origem dessa
tensão eu chamava se quique fez muita
companhia mesmo ficou hora de brincar
comigo mas
isso um dia mudou infelizmento um tempo
depois ela adoeceu e nem sei porque
ninguém me disse nada mas ficou muito
doente
eu fico tão fraco que nem conseguia
andar em um dia depois de o encontrar um
morto na minha cozinha foi a primeira
vez que eu lidei com a morte e não foi
nada bom
eu fiquei tão frustrado que a única
coisa que me acalmou fisgar teca 3
durante horas sem parar o hino disse que
então foi levado pela enxurrada e por
fim tinha perdido um amigo muito bom o
tempo foi passando e eu percebi que eu
só conseguia lidar com instituições da
mesma forma jogar jogar jogar jogar e
jogar só assim é que buscam se das
coisas margem e foi precisamente nessa
fase que eu percebi que era isso que eu
queria fazer da minha vida algo
relacionado aos jogos depois com a
escola tudo complicou a escola é
importante sim mas os professores não me
ensinavam navas relacionadas jogos nem
que eu fosse usar no meu futuro eu não
era bom aluno por isso mesmo nada me
interessava só mesmo as aulas de design
e trabalhos manuais
isso sim era ó são mais tarde quando
acaba o 9º ano eu seria entrar um curso
profissional de design digital 3d
era a oportunidade perfeita para evoluir
no design uma atuação em 3d entre muitas
outras coisas relacionadas com jogos foi
então que no primeiro ano do curso eu vi
que não era bem assim
a maioria das coisas que ensinavam eu já
sabia e o que realmente o prendia era
muito básico para eu conseguir usar isso
no meu futuro e eu fiquei tão bursite
com a minha vida acadêmica que resolve
então fazer algo por conta própria então
eu resolvi criar um canal do youtube
relacionadas jogos e foi um fiasco e
usei várias músicas conhecidas no fundo
os vídeos youtube apaga os meus filhos
todos por ter músicas com o cope raiva
que eu nem sabia disso na altura eu nem
me preocupei muito porque nem tinha
seguidores por isso eu mandei o youtube
para o meu dedo gostoso um pouco mais
tarde quando já estava no terceiro ano
do curso eu resolvi voltar a tentar
criar outro canal
mas desta vez não era do game era de
magia eu sempre adorei fazer truques de
magia por isso porque não tentar né
e eu tenho tido sucesso eu ganhei um
subscritor em apenas 3 dr o gol e depois
colocar alguns vídeos e efetiva algumas
visualizações de algum apoio e eu nem
sei como entretanto conheci mais pessoal
do youtube ficamos amigos
era tudo em outubro de game e em
conversa com eles no skype e incentivar
uma criar um canal de game e o risco é
mais uma vez mas sem músicas fundo sem
copyright sem nada desta vez no youtube
não mandar abaixo até foi mais difícil
foi criar um novo pro canal eu pensei em
dar place dark games dar portugal andrés
scotti pt não isso não stupid então a
minha loja que fui seguinte vamos chamar
dar e como vou fazer vídeos e os vídeos
são compostos por freios e vamos chamar
cara que frame mas com quatro por quatro
é sempre melhor né
e foi assim que ele saiu daqui dos
frangos do frei mas entretanto acabei o
curso foi trabalhar para o único sítio
onde as minhas qualificações eram
válidas num supermercado a noite
eu não tenho lugar precisava mesmo do
dinheiro para ajudar a minha mãe a pagar
as contas da casa
foram tempos difíceis de trabalhar duro
e ainda tinha que fazer vídeos
eu entrava juntos da noite e as oito da
manhã e quando chegava a casa ainda
tinha que fazer um vídeo por isso só
dormia mais ou menos quatro horas no dia
seguinte tinha que voltar a trabalhar
eu até ganhava vai mas não seria
arriscar em dedicar completamente o
youtube
eu ganhava muito menos mas fazia algo
que eu realmente amava e fiz a escolha
certa o canal subiu bastante e conseguir
pagar as contas com o dinheiro que
ganhava dos vídeos e ainda me divertir a
fazê lo e nem tudo é dinheiro claro mas
toda a gente precisa de comer e de se
cuidar por isso ainda bem que deu certo
tudo mudou a partir daí eu em vez de
cortar mal humorado para ir para o
trabalho eu cuidava cheio de vontade de
ler os comentários dos últimos vídeo e
construtiva primeira experiência com
vocês ao vivo no mit e eu nem tenho
palavras
foi aí que eu vi que quer fazer isso
para o resto da minha vida
ver a vossa felicidade a alma ver foi
brutal e pronto já tem o futuro que eu
sempre que isso só uma estava mesmo
evoluir e melhorar no que eu conseguisse
mas muita coisa aconteceu desde
problemas pessoais e vizinhos que não
deixavam fazer os vídeos por causa do
barulho muita festa aconteceu mesmo
muito gosto e por isso mesmo tive a
brilhante idéia de construir a cabana do
mal no meio do meu quarto sim eu sei que
é uma ideia estúpida mas resultou ela
isolou o som e isso é o que interessa
mas mesmo assim eles continuam a
reclamar e por isso mesmo tem que mudar
de casa urgentemente e está prestes a
acontecer mas não vou sozinho e por
falar em não estar sozinho e foi graças
ao youtube que eu encontrei a mulher da
minha vida que vocês conhecem por si
trip a tam é a primeira vez que eu a vi
e achei a mulher mais bonita do mundo
escreve a mente nós já éramos casados
ela que não sabia né e nós passamos
muito tempo junto com minhas duas que
serão alguns problemas de ter mais
motivação para os vídeos de um
somos uma força travada o fla em causa
em ok e nada disso poderia acontecer
sempre esteve na minha vida por isso
muito obrigado mesmo por tudo que tem
feito por mim hoje temos 400 mil amanhã
somos um milhão eu era bush e obrigado
[Música]